[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
's uh debate which
looks if it's going to be absolutely
fascinating The Mystery of the
Multiverse
multiverses are everywhere or at least
the theory is
everyone from physicist Stephen Hawking
and Brian Greene to Marvel Superheroes
have shown their support for the idea
but critics argue that not only is the
Multiverse improbable it's also a
fantasy and fundamentally unscientific
as the theory can never be tested
should we reject the grand claims and
leave Multiverse theories to the pages
of comic books are tales of the
Multiverse really sticking plaster
solutions for a Big Bang Theory in
trouble
or should we take Multiverse Theory as
seriously as its proponents and accept
that modern science has moved beyond the
bounds of experiment into that of the
imagination so with me to discuss the
topic a remarkable panel
Michelle Kaku is a leading string
theorist and one of the founders of
Stringfield Theory he's written a host
of best-selling books including the god
equation and parallel worlds Sabina
hosenfelder
specializes in the foundation of physics
she's a research fellow at the Frankfurt
Institute for advanced studies and leads
the superfluid and dark matter team
and Roger Penrose who needs no
introduction is a world-renowned
mathematician physicist and philosopher
of science
he was awarded the Nobel Prize in 2020
for his work on black holes
so I'm going to give each of them just
three minutes to address the central
question which is does the Multiverse
exist or should we reject the grand
claims and leave the theory to science
fiction so missio it's all yours
thank you very much well the most
successful physical theory of all time
is called the quantum theory and it's
accurate within one part
in 10 billion and the world economy is
based on the quantum principle lasers
the internet this conversation is made
possible because of the quantum theory
but the quantum theory is based on a
space principle that electrons can be
two places at the same time
now Einstein hated that principle he
once said that the more successful the
quantum theory becomes the sillier it
looks well sorry about that Albert but
it turns out that the world economy is
based on the fact that electrons can be
in multiple States at the same time
until you measure it now let's apply
this Theory to Einstein's theory
Einstein says that the universe is a
bubble of some sort which is expanding
that's called The Big Bang Theory that
this is correct and we quantize the
universe then the universe can be in
multiple States at the same time in
other words instead of a bubble it's a
bubble bath and these bubbles can
Collide and when they Collide they form
a bigger bubble or a bubble can fission
in half to create two smaller Bubbles
and what is that called that is called
the Big Bang
and how do you prove it well so far the
data seems to go into favor of
inflationary Theory an inflationary
theory in terms based on the idea that
universes are being born all the time
even as we speak Big Bangs have been
happening someplace in this great
Universe of ours and then where does
inflation Theory come from well one
theory that seems to predict inflation
theory is called String Theory which is
what I do for a living and if I have
time later I'll talk more about it but
then the question is how do we visualize
these higher interventions well Logan
Lori and Steve Weinberg gave us a way to
visualize these higher Dimensions think
of your living room in your living room
there are hundreds of radio signals from
radio stations all over the world in
your living room but your video has
decode here it's not true it's not to
the radio station your radio is only
tuned to one frequency now replace radio
with electrons your living room is full
of electrons the electrons are pirates
dinosaurs aliens from other stars and
stuff all in our living room but you are
no longer vibrating in Phase with them
says Steve Weinberg in other words yes
there is a Multiverse computer out there
but they're probably
ability of hearing them I've been
coherent with them is too small to be
measured one problem we give our PhD
students is calculate the probability
you'll wake up on Mars tomorrow
well it's a finite number you can
calculate it but tomorrow I suspect you
will wind up in your room you will have
to wait and with the universe to walk to
wake up on Mars but is it possible well
yeah and that's what separates this from
Marvel Comics Marvel Comics all these
Feats of imagination are for free in
real physics we can calculate their
probabilities of these things happening
and you will have to wait longer than
the time of the universe worry about
that Spiderman
thank you Michelle
so Sabina
so I think that all those Multiverse
theories which we have seen popping up
in the foundations of physics come from
the same misunderstanding which is that
we have physicists who come to believe
that the mathematics that they deal with
is actually real so they typically the
way that it happens is that they have a
theory which makes some predictions that
agree with
observations and they take that to mean
that because some of the things that
they can predict agree with observations
all the mathematics that is in a theory
has to be real and to me that's
completely insane you know that's like
saying okay so Harry Potter the Harry
Potter goes to King cross King's cross
station which is a real place therefore
magic is real that's just not a good
logical argument
um but I think it's a little bit
a false dichotomy to say well it's
either science or it belongs into comic
books there are some things in between
so I think multiple theories have some
value as being philosophical
speculations or maybe some people find
them inspiring they have certainly
inspired a lot of artists writers and so
on and I think there's value in that
also I think one has to keep in mind
that even though they're not testable at
the moment maybe sometime in the future
they will become testable so for most of
those Multiverse is the reason we can't
experimentally access them is that
nothing travels faster than the speed of
light for all we currently know so maybe
at some point in the future that we will
be able to overcome the speed of light
limit in which case multiverses might
actually become testable thank you
Sabina Roger
well I had a bit of trouble when I saw
the topic of this meeting
um not really knowing what people meant
by the Multiverse I think many of the
Alternatives that I've come across I
would use up all my time try to
distinguish between them I think I'll
comment it mainly on what mikio was
talking about
namely quantum mechanics and the issue
within quantum mechanics you seem to
have to consider all sorts of
alternative things which happen
simultaneously now the trouble here
is the theory in my view it may well be
as mentioned earlier the most successful
theory that we've ever had the trouble
is it may be successful but it's not
really consistent with itself the
trouble is it consists of two parts one
of them is what one can call the
Schrodinger equation how the quantum
State evolves in time and the other has
to do with what happens when we make a
measurement and the two things are
inconsistent because if you imagine
making a measurement then that involves
a measuring device and that seems to
come in from outside the measuring
device is not considered to be a Quantum
system itself if it is then it doesn't
measure anything so I have a real
trouble with Quantum Mechanics for this
sort of reason
it is clearly a successful Theory it
clearly has enormous implications that
we see agree with the physical world
however it has this big blemish it was
quite pointed out by schroding himself
he described this thing in his
hypothetical cat which was dead and
alive at the same time and he was more
or less not saying as some people say
well maybe if you're clever enough you
could build a Schrodinger's cat which is
Dead Alive at the same time Schrodinger
is pointing out the absurdity of the
situation more or less to say there is
something wrong with the theory and
that's my view is that there is
something wrong with the theory even
though it is such a wonderful Theory
what's wrong with the theory has to do
with
superpositions which are not just say
electrons in here and here at the same
time but big bodies which are here and
here at the same time and in my opinion
if one considers the foundational
principles of the other great theory of
20th century physics namely Einstein's
general theory of relativity
you realize that there are issues of
conflict between the general principles
of general relativity and those of
quantum mechanics and then in my view
that it's not just that general
relativity has to be quantized in other
words brought under the general scheme
of quantum mechanics
that quantum mechanics needs help itself
and the help it needs is to get rid of
all these different Alternatives one
thing happens not the superposition of
all the different things
and one can understand that by exploring
how general relativity relates to
macroscopic superpositions now I'm not
going to go into that here it's not the
place to talk about it but the
conclusion one seems to come to is that
when you have a big enough body which is
in the superposition of two places it
has a lifetime in that state which very
rapidly becomes one or the other and a
theory which improves upon quantum
mechanics brings in general relativity
in the right way it's not quantizing
general relativity which people often
say is a big the major problem of
physics if you like is gravitising
quantum mechanics we have to see what
happens when the principles of general
relativity are brought to bear on
quantum mechanics and then you see that
you don't have all these superpositions
of different things at once you can have
one thing or another the bigger the
thing is the more rapidly it becomes one
or the other in a perfectly coherent
scheme now I'm afraid that at the moment
we do not have a complete theory of this
nature regardless of the biggest
challenge
of current physics to see how to bring
these theories together and to rid
quantum mechanics of this big blemish
namely the measurement problem or the
fact that superpositions seem to be
present in quantum mechanics and really
we want a theory which has one
alternative all the other resisting for
macroscopic bodies thank you uh Roger so
before embarking on talking about a
number of different themes we wanting to
explore with the panel I I just like to
get a little bit clearer the question
that Roger said opposed there that the
Multiverse is used to refer to all sorts
of things very different sorts of
Multiverse
where there are some claim there are
infinite uh
universes other than our own and there
are different versions of this so I
think just just briefly to try and get
clear what the different positions are
of those are on the panel here so miss
you I understand you as arguing that
there are an infinite number of other
universes with potentially different
laws than this one is that correct
yes uh screen theory for example
probably has an unaccountable number of
infinite universes and of course that
begs the question people often ask me
well that's true then is Elvis Presley
still alive in one of these parallel
universes Well it can't be ruled out
maybe he's still belting out his hits in
another parallel universe but let me
make a challenge a challenge to everyone
in the audience we're dancing around the
question is there a Theory of Everything
which can unify General activity with
quantum mechanics let me give you a
challenge if anyone in the audience can
come up with a theory that satisfies
three Criterion it'll probably be
recognized at the next Einstein first
your theory has to include general
relativity at least in the low energy
realm their relativity second it has to
include the standard model with of
course 36 quarks and anti quarks three
generations of subatomic particles and
the whole slew of young Mills particles
it has to include the standard model and
three your theory has to be free of
anomalies and divergences and
mathematical inconsistency and if you in
the audience ever find this table Theory
then tell me first
well we'll try and come to your Rescue
Mission
together yeah yeah very good so uh Roger
sometimes I think your view is described
as a Multiverse but it's a cyclical
Multiverse it's the idea that this
universe
uh uh did have something before the Big
Bang and there was uh a previous
universe and that in fact if you look
back indefinitely there are a whole
series of
um expansions and contractions going on
uh in sequence is that right and would
you describe that as a Multiverse or do
you think actually you really see that
as one universe is just that it goes
through a series of stages
certainly only one Universe there's no
multi-universe about it and it doesn't
contract I should say but never mind
no the point of view that's completely
different of course what I was talking
about yes now is the issue of of the
quantum mechanical apparently multitudes
of different things but yes what you're
pointing out is this model which I put
forward some years ago where you have a
sequence of
phases or eons as I call them but
they're all part of one Universe
moreover things which happen in the one
before hours influence hours in ways
which are observationally testable and
some of these have been tested and we
see positive conclusions from these
things so I I don't regard this really
as being as you were saying suggesting I
think that this is not a monthly verse
in any normal I don't know we can is
there a normal sense of the word
Multiverse but it isn't one in the sense
that I've heard Express yeah but thank
you yeah so Sabina let's cut come on
there the the First theme I'd like to
put to the panel which is do scientific
theories have to be testable
and does Multiverse Theory threaten this
basic principle
um yes and yes
maybe let me expand
s um I I actually don't know anything
anyone who works on multiple stuff or
generally in the foundations of physics
who would question that theories have to
be testable rather what's going on is a
little bit more subtle
um there there are three different
arguments that people make about
testability in the foundations one is
that the theory may just not be testable
yet
um that's typically an argument that
string theorists make so in principle it
makes some predictions but we would have
to build because either the size of the
Milky Way to test it so maybe one day
we'll be able to do it but not anytime
soon
um the second one is a switch and bait
tactic where they switch the overall
principle that could be the Multiverse
or it could be dark matter or Theory of
Everything or something for a very
specific model so you have this
overarching idea like the Multiverse and
someone comes and says well it's not
testable then they can say well I have
this very particular model for the
Multiverse which makes a particular
prediction for example there are some
multiverses in which
um the universes can Collide basically
and it leaves a signature in the cosmic
microwave background which is something
that you can look for but then if
someone goes and blocks and doesn't find
it they say oh it was only this
particular version of the Multiverse
that has been ruled out we still believe
that the overall idea of the Multiverse
is correct and it's the same for Dark
Matter particles so
um basically you can indefinitely amend
your theories whenever there's
conflicting evidence coming in you go
back and say well here's a different
model
I'll forget about it
um the third one um is the argument
which I briefly mentioned in the
beginning already that they say well
actually I have a theory that does make
some testable predictions and that have
been tested therefore I also believe
that all the other mathematics is real
even though you can't test it I see
thank you so miss you
um science needs to be testable and your
theory isn't
spring theory is that we'll get four
experiments experiment number one
the Fermi laboratory is for the first
time in history found an anomalous
behavior in a Magnetic Moment of the
muon which indicates a new Force outside
the standard model this is huge it means
that quantum physics is being shaken to
the core if the result holds up with
Fermi laboratory a deviation in this
added model number two dark matter dark
matter will collide with protons leaving
a spark in a spark chamber which in turn
can be measured and then compared
against the different Dark Matter
predictions of string theory like the
fotino the funkido is a particle in a
string theory which has no charge is
massive and obeys all the properties of
dark matter and it could be found any
day in a spiral chamber three deviations
from Newton's inverse Square law we know
the universe is three-dimensional
because as we learn in grade school
gradually Dimension diminishes at the
inverse square but what about the
inverse Cube the inverse Quantic
University
if the universe has a higher Dimension
then gravity should taper off in the
laboratory not in outer space in your
laboratory faster than usual number four
eventually the esa and NASA will launch
Lisa into outer space Visa is a laser
interformity space antenna that line to
pick up radiation from a trillionth of a
second after the instant of the Big Bang
in other words we hope to get baby
pictures baby pictures from the infant
universe as it emerges from the wolf
and hopefully this is of course keep
your fingers crossed hopefully we'll
pick up evidence of an umbilical cord an
umbilical cord that connects our
universe with a baby universe and again
all four of these things do not require
a particle accelerator the size of the
Milky Way galaxy these results are
coming in now even as we speak results
from premium episodes about dark matter
and discussions of the inverse Square
law these are things that can be done in
our lifetime and even then we're not
talking about direct measurement of
these things we're talking about
indirect measurement we have never been
to the Sun
we have never been inside a DNA molecule
but how do we know so much about this
sign have we been there no have we been
inside a DNA molecule no we know that by
indirect analysis most of physics is
done indirectly so it's a it's a false
scarecrow to introduce the idea that you
have to have a particle accelerated the
size of the Milky Way galaxy that's a
direct confirmation of string theory I'm
talking about the same way we know so
much about the Sun and so much about DNA
molecules by indirect measurements which
lends us to believe that string theory
is correct
so I'll just ask Sabina to respond to
you in a moment but but just but
initially you pointed to lots of
um questions that there are about our
current uh uh theories of the universe
you know Dark Matter the recent muon
experiment so forth but can you really
point to those as evidence of the
Multiverse Theory I mean aren't there
lots of other possible accounts of that
and indeed they remain deep puzzles but
you know the fact there are deep puzzles
with our current measurements of various
things doesn't doesn't
show us that the Multiverse theory is uh
has been proved to be the case does it
well there are degrees of confirmation
in other words that have a theory
completely confirmed takes a lot of time
think of the atomic theory how long did
it take for us to confirm Democritus
conjecture two thousand years ago that
there's such a thing as Adam it took two
thousand years before we had the first
clear pictures of atoms but in between
then we had plenty of indirect
measurements plenty of indirect theories
that indicated that he has atoms were
real same thing with Multiverse it'll
take time to get all the facts in place
but all the facts so far point in the
direction of the Multiverse okay thank
you so Sabino we might not have direct
evidence but we might have indirect
evidence and the parallel with the uh
the the uh collider the size of the
Milky Way is uh is misleading
well so
observation
observations uh that Mishu just
mentioned if they were found they would
not be evidence for string theory
um it's just wrong I I know a lot of
string theorists uh serious string
theorists and I think none of them would
make that claim and I can explain this
in great detail but it would take a long
time maybe I'll just take an example
deviations from Newton Square law this
is something that people have looked for
for a long time
there are many ways to explain them
could be an additional new Force could
be additional Dimensions but it's got
nothing to do with strings it's
certainly the case that there have been
some predictions inspired by String
Theory which would also lead to these
deviations but we Face What's called the
inverse problem we have maybe one day we
will have some observations and we try
to infer what the theory was that gave
rise to them and this is just completely
underdetermined as the philosophers put
it
there's no way to get out string theory
in particular
do you want to respond to that machine
well as I mentioned before it took two
thousand years to completely verify the
atomic theory now we have pictures
pictures taken from scanning finally
microscopes but in between there were
many partial results that gave us
indirect proof of the existence of atoms
Einstein in 1905 was able to show using
statistical mechanics that atoms were
probably the size that we think they are
today 10 to the minus eight centimeters
and so I think not in one flash we're
going to prove that the Multiverse
theory is correct or the string theory
is correct but the overwhelming weight
of evidence will point in a direction
and let me make another challenge
another challenge to everybody in this
room
you are free to not like any of these
theories but if you don't like these
theories propose your own the second law
of Thermodynamics says that it's always
more difficult to create a theory than
to destroy ethereum you can dislike any
of these theories that we talked about
today but I challenge you come up with a
better one well there's a excellent
opportunity to introduce Roger into this
conversation
well I'm not a particle physicist so I
don't claim to have a better Theory than
String Theory although I'm pretty
disappointed by the conclusions I mean
just to mention how other theories have
taken a long time to confirm it sounds
it tells me nothing about String Theory
I mean string theory proposes the wrong
number of dimensions of space for
instance it proposes the wrong sign for
the cosmological constants for instance
all sorts of things which have come out
of string theory are just wrong now you
could get around this one way or another
I know people like to tuck all these
extra Dimensions into a little tiny ball
they haven't answered the question that
I've often raised in my books about that
which is that it doesn't really solve a
problem I mean there are big huge
problems facing string theory I didn't
quite know why we're talking about this
with the Multiverse anyway because
string theory
is just is a particular Theory which I
don't think has much in the way of
support for it it's got a lot of people
who argue for it but that's not
scientific support there aren't
experiments which support String Theory
but that's really a different question
from the Multiverse isn't it are we are
we talking about String Theory or the
Multiverse here
has been criticized for being a
Multiverse Theory oh but I don't mind
because if even if you take a look at
Newton's laws of motion they are also in
some sense a theory with an infinite
number of possible solutions your
strength here is an infinite number of
solutions well so does Newton's Laws
Maxwell's equations they all have an
infinite number of solutions but how do
you make sense of it by looking at the
initial conditions that's how you can
prove that Newton's theory is correct by
starting with the baseball starting with
a rocket same thing with student Theory
you start with the initial conditions of
the universe and then you can project
into the future the problem is
experimental we do not know the initial
conditions of the universe therefore we
cannot directly compare it to a
Multiverse Theory but that's an
experimental question which I think will
be answered as we have more and more
satellites detect things like gravity
waves in outer space face all right miss
you some people would say that
um
what we need to do when we're proposing
theories is to apply good ancient
philosophical principle of Occam's razor
that you generate as few new entities as
possible
but the proposal that there's an
infinite number of other universes seems
on the surface it to rather break that
print principle do you not think that a
more modest proposal might be
more comfortable people are trying
people have tried for decades to tear
apart the Multiverse Theory but as I
mentioned is the legitimate
interpretation of a Quantum mechanic it
agrees with all the experiments now
there are other interpretations the
important mechanics you don't have to
believe in the Multiverse theme if you
get 10 to the uh I mean 10 billion one
part in 10 billion accuracy for an
experiment there are other
interpretations of quantum mechanics but
the Multiverse interpretation is the
cleanest simplest interpretation because
you simply drop one of the personalists
of quantum theory so the Multiverse
theory is actually simpler than the
quantum mechanics that I teach at at
City University of New York by dropping
the postulate that you make it that you
make an observation and the wave
function collapses you actually simplify
quantum mechanics would you agree no
no
I don't understand all that I mean
you've got a
the idea is you I mean this is the many
worlds what's that got to do with the
other things there's so many things
which seem to be brought in in relation
to the Multiverse that I'm really
confused about what's been talked about
I mean quantum mechanics yes if you
don't have the collapse going on in
quantum mechanics you have all these
superpositions going on which we don't
see in the world something you've got to
do about that but what's that got to do
with the Multiverse just postulating
that they're all there doesn't help
and that's a different Multiverse anyway
it's not the Multiverse where you I
don't know I really get very confused
about
how these problems are resolved by
having a Multiverse it doesn't doesn't
to me help anything okay let me move on
to our our next theme here which is if
experimental evidence for the Multiverse
is at least short on the ground if not
impossible
what's driving the multifirst uh story
is it because uh
in a Big Bang Theory is in trouble and
uh and we need something to solve that
is is that what's what's uh what's
driving it Sabina
well so to some extent that's a
sociological question about why do
physicists do what they do but
um maybe it's worth saying a little bit
more about the question about the Big
Bang Theory being uh in trouble I can
only guess what Michio was referring to
when he was talking about the
gravitational waves in the early
Universe I suppose it was the B modes in
the CMB is that right
detectors like Lisa laser interferometry
space antenna being pushed by the
European Space Agency in NASA yeah but
what's the signal primordial
gravitational waves
that's right gravitational weight before
300 000 years after the big bang at the
instant of creation itself
yeah um right so so why would this be
evidence for the Multiverse I suppose
because you say it would be evidence for
a particular type of inflation is that
the idea because once you have data from
a true intimacy after the big bang you
can run the videotape backwards and see
what alternate universe is it's really
into a second before the Big Bang match
the data a trillionth of a second after
the big bang and so in other words in
this sense we can actually get data from
before creation itself from before T is
equal to zero by extrapolating post Big
Bang radiation to the pre-big van era
and then of course String Theory gives
you a number of predictions about the
three big bang universe that's what
streams in regards and if you find that
result for everything and so you can
actually calculate the free Big Bang
radiation and compare it with the post
Big Bang radiation of gravity
space-based brand new detectors yeah but
what's it got to do with the Multiverse
because this allows you to extract out
the key the keywords
except the whole puts everything in
London you know which of the Multiverse
ideas is the correct one just like doing
this one newton quads has an infinite
number of solutions for baseballs rocket
ships or Marbles and independent
resolution which one is the correct one
it depends on your initial condition we
do not know the initial conditions of
the Big Bang itself once we have the
initial condition of the Big Bang then
you can start to rule out uh universes
that are that don't match and out of the
Multiverse you can you can get the birth
of our universe itself
so starting with a Multiverse Theory you
then get the theory of the universe
itself by running the videotape
backwards
well but obviously just to describe our
own Universe we don't need all the other
infinitely many universes so um
all the other universes that are do not
correspond to the experiment
well but maybe maybe let me step back a
little bit so I'm not saying that
um all those other universes do not
exist
I'm trying to say that science can't
tell us anything about whether they
exist or do not exist it's just not in
the realm of science I don't have a big
problem when people talk about
multiverses of whatever type if that may
be the many words interpretation or
Eternal inflation or the string theory
landscape and so on I get a problem if
they say it's it's science because it
isn't it's a weird kind of platalism
where scientists come to believe in the
existence of mathematics
as I said every year as more data comes
in from fermilab from CERN every year
we'll have better and better data which
will allow us to zero in on this Theory
without having to build an accelerator
the size of the Milky Way galaxy we're
going to get asymptotic and closer and
closer just like with the atomic theory
every year we get more evidence of the
atomic theory even if we don't have
photographs of the of the atom itself
same thing with string theory we'll get
closer and closer because more data will
come in which I think will verify String
Theory but it isn't it one one challenge
missio to to this proposal has been that
if you make an overall proposal to
account for how things are currently as
I say you want usually operate within
the principle that it should be as
simple as possible you have argued well
it is quite simple I think the the
Occam's razor principle is you don't
generate entities unnecessarily and an
infinite number of universes just breaks
that principle coaching horses but the
other other people have said well if you
are proposing something as an
explanation of what there is here but
you have no evidence for it what
difference is there between a Multiverse
proposal and the traditional religious
proposal of God which you say well we
can't explain everything here we're
going to pose that it's all made by
something else namely God isn't the idea
that everything here comes from the
Multiverse really just a scientific
version of theology no I don't think so
because every time someone makes a
theological statement it stands on its
own marriage or whatever forever because
there's no experimental evidence
supporting it it's just pure conjecture
but as I mentioned there are at least
four major ways in which to verify the
theory and each one gets us closer to a
complete verification of the theory not
one experiment that clinches it all at
once there's no smoking gun but the same
thing with the Big Bang Theory there's
no there was no smoking gun for The Big
Bang Theory for many decades and so that
what I'm saying is it gets us closer to
truth but religion does not give us get
us closer to truth it's the same
arguments made thousands of years ago
are identical the arguments that will be
made 1000 of years from now
in religion
do you think uh Roger that one of the
reasons that
the Multiverse and the version that
Michelle is putting forwards has been
proposed is because of the concern that
quantum mechanics
has built into it and uncertainty
which Einstein was certainly
uncomfortable with
and it's somehow trying to get rid of
the unknownness in quantum mechanics and
to say well we're just going to generate
entities for every every bit so that
it's no longer unknown
but if that's what it's doing it's not
very impressive I mean quantum mechanics
has a problem and I think that's true
despite it being the most wonderful
Theory we've ever had or something
um it's it has a it has a deep problem
but I don't quite see why that has
anything to do with this
Multiverse issue which has to do with
string theory I mean there seems to be a
big confusion
about different concepts different
problems that people have and calling
them all the Multiverse or something I
don't quite see it solves any of them
actually I mean you can Maxwell's
equations have lots of solutions yeah of
course they do so to Einstein's
equations so the Newton's equations
why does that drive us in the direction
of a Multiverse I just haven't got that
argument at all and what do you think
what is driving that I mean it's very
popular isn't it it's it sells books uh
sells theories uh it drives science
fiction what is it about the idea of you
know another Universe to this one that
we found so appealing I had no idea
maybe if I could say something about it
I think it depends on what we mean by
popular it's arguably popular in the
Popular Science sense you read popular
science articles about it people write
books about it and those books uh
celebrate where we go to festivals and
people talk about it right but if you
look at what's actually happening in the
community in physics there are very very
few people working on it like so we we
have the foundations of physics and then
as there's a sub-discipline of the
foundations of physics world we deal
with quantum gravity and then there's a
sub-discipline of the sub-discipline
where there is a fringe part where
people talk about the Multiverse that
it's it's not in any meaningful way
popular in physics it's just not true so
which brings up the question why does
the general public find it so
interesting and I find this quite easy
to understand it's interesting brain
gymnastics you know I like thinking
about the possibility that there are
infinite infinitely many copies of me
out there somewhere in the universe and
they're living their lives in other ways
I also like movies about it I like it if
it if it appears in books you know it
makes for good fiction and I I don't
necessarily have a big problem with this
I just think we shouldn't conflate the
fiction with the science
Michelle it makes for good fiction
well yeah I mean take a look at
Psychology and what cells
the idea of parallel universe is it's
not a new one it goes back to the
Ancients they talked about dream worlds
they talked about hypothetical world or
for that matter look at Alice in
Wonderland uh the the gateway to
Wonderland is the Wormhole uh the first
conceptualization of a wormhole in the
English language was through the looking
glass by Lewis Carroll otherwise known
as Charles Dodson a professional
mathematician at Oxford so it's an old
theme but what's new about this old
theme is the fact that it now has a
basis in physical reality so far the
Multiverse Theory as applied to Quantum
Mechanics which is many world's Theory
agrees with all the data in fact there's
no way to differentiate the Copenhagen
interpretation from the many world's
interpretation they are identical with
regards to experimental verification so
you don't have to believe in the
Multiverse Theory to be a quantum
mechanical physicist because the data
from the many world theory and the data
from the Copenhagen interpretation are
identical but when you start to talk
about cosmology if you start to talk
about the universe where it all came
from then you start to ask these
philosophical questions about where did
the universe come from is there another
copy of Me In Another Universe someplace
that's what resonates with the audience
I think because people wonder about
these things there's a poem by Robert
Frost the road not taken and you always
wonder what was what would have happened
if I took that other road with a fork in
the road this is an internal question
and that's why it resonates with
Hollywood because now we have at least a
physical Theory which entertains the
concept that yes there are many roads to
reality
thank you Michelle so let me just uh end
briefly with a final theme which is
are we always going to be in a situation
where our broadest accounts of the
universe have Elements which are
untestable
well I think untestable
but in principle and testable I just we
don't have enough energy or enough money
or something like that I mean a lot of
things hadn't been tested because
they're pretty difficult to do
an example of that is the issue of the
reduction of the state in quantum
mechanics or the collapse of the wave
function of course you have to have a
good alternative theory about what level
do you expect to see that and there are
experiments which are proposed at the
moment some which have been performed
and haven't quite got there maybe it'll
take a long time but these are honest
experiments which will show if they come
out the way I expect actually
that there is something not quite right
about quantum mechanics and that you
don't have all these other universes
existing and so on this one thing
happens and that thing happens in a
certain lifetime which you can get a
good estimate for according to some of
these schemes and seems to me that's the
way science progresses I mean you
suggest experiments and
some of them are quite expensive and so
it takes a long time for people to get
around to doing them or they may be
technically very difficult such as ones
I'm talking about here
but does that would would this be
considered to be arguments against
multiverses I mean suppose you are now a
very good experiment comes up which
shows that the quantum superposition
does become one or the other in a
certain lifetime which maybe is
predicted now does that say oh well we
don't have to talk about multiverses
anymore or is it really a completely
different argument that's being
presented here I just feel that they're
too much fuzziness too much particularly
arguments from String Theory which I I
don't really see I suppose I was
I want to go to a small general question
is is there
something about the way that we put our
theories together which means that there
is always an element of untestability
somewhere so that as an example of the
sort of thing I mean so a Heisenberg can
certainly be interpreted as uh as
advocating the view that physics is not
uncovering reality uh and that's because
it can't do so in some at some level
there's some uh residual element which
is about the limitation of Being Human
and making observations would mean that
we we can't get through to it another
way of thinking about it would be you
know are there elements of science for
example the the notion that the universe
is governed by laws
uh which is a essential idea to science
but you know can we really test the idea
that the universe is governed by laws is
there some is there something in it and
and are there therefore some essential
assumptions as it were in any theory
that we can't get at well I mean imagine
tomorrow the laws are all changed and I
mean that could happen it I don't expect
it to but uh I can't quite see I mean
all the observations that have been made
up to date I mean tell us would be world
has to be according to the physics that
we understand now I mean we just that
it seems to work pretty well and uh very
well under certain circumstances
and um
I mean take general relativity it's now
extraordinarily well tested I mean
things like a clock down here runs at a
different rate from a clock up here well
you know it used to be this Tower no
it's from
here to about there
sure I mean these things are confirmed
these are really precise things the
theory says and experiments can be done
and they say yes this Theory agrees is
what we observe now strings theory is
nothing like that
and in these postulated ideas about
other universes around there's nothing
like that so I can't quite see why we
should consider those ideas
are as comparable with these wonderful
things we do get from the physics we
know
yep Sabrina do you think there's a
residual element always that we can't
get up
so I was about to say pretty much the
same as Roger
um I think that underlying
the scientific method itself there's
always
the problem of inference the way that
you put it or that or the way that draws
a popularized it uh with his analogy to
the chicken uh the chicken is fed every
morning at exactly 9 A.M by the farmer
and it thinks that this is a law of
nature until one day the farmer comes
and chops off the head
so we have no telling that the laws of
nature will still work tomorrow this is
just something which underlies the
entire scientific methodology that we
just assumed to be true but we can't
test it itself because how would we test
it yeah right but there is a somewhat
more innocent example of something that
we can't test which is anything that is
too rare to happen in the time that we
measure it with an example may be proton
decay which is something that we've
looked for for a long time but we still
haven't seen a single proton decaying
but there are also other things like for
example the cosmological constant may
not actually be exactly constant it may
very very slowly change
in you know a couple of billion years
but we'd never be able to test it and
that that's an interesting example I
think because what the cosmological
constant does eventually determines the
ultimate fate of our universe and do you
think there's a is there a a place for
proposing theories that we don't have uh
evidence for or that perhaps we can't
have evidence for but which somehow do
function to
um holds our overall account of the
world together in some ways that is
there some purpose in in that exercise
even if we think well actually this
isn't really science it's something else
I think there is a purpose in that I
think it's worth thinking certainly if
you can have a scheme which is simpler
in some respect and it may not be
testable but on the other hand it gives
you a an overall picture which is
simpler than one which is different but
still not testably different so it's
certainly worth thinking about such
things
but I think that it's really going over
the top when I was talking about this
Multiverse ideas
which partly come from
things about quantum mechanics which I
think aren't correct and someday we will
I hope see what should replace them
but I I can't quite see why we should be
driven into this idea of all these
universes coexisting but that I haven't
understood so it's a missionary do you
um
uh do you think there will always be a
remainder of um
topics that we are not able to explain
which are untestable at some level
yes there is a point in which all the
known laws of physique collapsed
completely and that's the Planck energy
the plug energy is 10 to the 19 billion
electron evolves that is a quadrillion
times more powerful than our most
powerful machine the Large Hadron
Collider it is the point at which black
holes and Big Bangs all of that stuff
takes place in the realm of The Chronic
energy where Einstein's equations become
useless Einstein's equations diverge
completely at the flank energy the laws
of quantum mechanics you have to have
higher Loop diagrams to control the
diversity it's a real mess but that is
the energy of the center of a black hole
that is the energy of the Big Bang the
most interesting place is in the
universe are beyond our mathematical
ability because they exist at the plug
energy in fact the only Theory which can
operate at the product energy is string
theory but that that's a whole other
question but the question you ask is is
there a point where the laws of physics
says we know that break down and the
answer is yes two places the center of a
black hole at the beginning of the
universe that's where the punk Energy
starts to come in wormholes dominate all
sorts of crazy things begin to happen we
have to think about the possibility of
time travels uh gateways of the
universes it becomes a real mess with
the block energy
yes well obviously the question is
whether we whether we take those
descriptions seriously isn't it no I
don't think we need to
I mean the big bang is well I don't want
to go into this because the Big Bang is
a different story from the singularities
and black holes they're completely
different story and to try and apply the
same arguments to both is in my view
quite wrong I mean I had the wrong view
myself for a long time
so I no there's nothing against
contemplating these things I just happen
to think
for what I regard as good reasons that
the singularity in the Big Bang are sort
of an utterly different nature from the
singularities in black holes and
this difference is extremely important
it leads to the second law of
Thermodynamics it's part it's part of
the story if they weren't different we
wouldn't have a second law of
Thermodynamics I mean these are things
in physics that we see very blatant
things in physics which if you trace
them back
it leads us to the conclusion that what
goes at the Big Bang is utterly
different from a singularities and black
holes and therefore to put them in the
same category and saying String Theory
or multiverses or something is going to
resolve that I can't see that at all
very much so well I'm afraid that is all
we have time for I think you'll all
agree an absolutely fascinating
conversation
[Applause]